I've been taking Ivermectin for my cancer for eight months now lately
I've been seeing reports that the Ivermectin may be tainted. Do you have an
opinion about that? Well, I do because I don't trust any pharmaceutical companies.
That's just me. Very cynical. I apologize. But doing this for almost 40 years now
you get you tend to get cynical about the medical profession. I'm not saying
there's not a need for them. I'm not saying there's not great doctors and I'm
not saying there's not great medications out there and drugs out there that I've
saved people's life. But for everyone that has saved a person's life there's
probably 10 that have killed people. So it is I've said over and over again that you
know remember that bed is all and Ivermectin though they are the latest. I hate
to say fan. Okay, but I've been taking care of people with cancer since 1998 or
1999. So 26 years now going on 27 years and I've seen things come and go. Okay. I'll use
an example of Rick Simpson. Well, it was about five six years ago. I tell you I had three
questions on Rick Simpson oil and just about every zoom call. It was because that's all you've
heard about. It's Rick Simpson, Rick Simpson, Rick Simpson, and that's when THC and CBD was new
to the market and it was the hottest latest fan in treating everything and it cured everything.
We've soon come to learn that CBD, well, it's a good product for a lot of things especially
if you have CPN1 defects, genetic defects and things it can be very helpful but it is not.
There isn't a cure all for everything. There just there isn't and you heard back
10 years ago to five years ago it's all we heard about is Rick Simpson oil for carry cancer.
Rick Simpson oil is very high concentration THC so it's very psychotropic and gosh, question after
question about can I use the Rick Simpson oil for this and that blah blah blah blah blah. Well,
it wasn't the cure at all either. I'm not saying it didn't work for some people but I'm
her back to the fan medicine or this same thing. You know, then about five years ago so all we
heard about is the Joe Tippen's protocol and fed medicine. Well, we've seen miracles with it
but we've seen, you know, more than that many people that did it and seemingly did nothing for them.
Same thing with Iverbectad, even though Dr. Bacchus is publishing his success stories,
left it right, sending him out and figuring out his email list. He sends you about two emails a day.
You know, the truth is he may have, you know, 10,000 people that are following his protocol,
maybe a hundred thousand people that are following his protocol, he's getting it, you know,
I don't have that many different testimonies of success from him. So just remember, you know,
that anything can work for anybody and many times it not only doesn't work but it could
do harm, but it could do harm especially when you're talking about a drug. So just just keep that
in mind. Do I believe that the pharmaceutical companies are purposefully, that's the talk out there,
you know, the tone is that the pharmaceutical companies now, you know, they were so against Iverbectad
during COVID, you know, bashing it, Iverbectad is bad which is pretty hard to understand why
were they doing that when they were the ones selling Iverbectad and they were the ones not
allowing Iverbectad to be sold, could it say they made a profit selling it? Well, they made a bigger
profit selling the vaccine and there was other various things going on with the vaccine. Now we're
learning that the MLRNA vaccines are cause of cancer. We said it a long time ago, but the proof is
now coming out. The research is coming out. So and then all of a sudden they changed their tune
about a year ago and yes, everybody could get Iverbectad and that made everyone suspicious, you know,
anybody that's been dealing with the medical profession of the drug companies over the years,
that puts out your little spidey senses that all of a sudden they just okayed something. Oh, what
is going on with that? And some people have said that different independent laboratories have
tested different Iverbectads on the market and they can be tainted and there's people out there
that said that. Now personally, I've never seen those studies. I don't know if they're true. I don't
know if this is just another conspiracy theory. I don't know. I'm just saying that I think
in Venezuela and Iverbectad can be used for cancer and if somebody is in dire straits and
we need to do everything that doing that can be an option. I just I you just have to use everything
with caution in a lot of prayer and be careful. If you've been taking Iverbectad for eight months now
and you're stable, I would consider going off it. I've had other questions in the past where people
said I don't have my husband doesn't have cancer but he he's been taking Iverbectad to prevent it.
I don't I think it's I don't think that's a good idea. I don't think he should be on a medication
to try to prevent disease. I don't think that's I think he should let your body try to prevent disease.
You know, you take nutrition, you do dietary things, you exercise, you do all sorts of things
to prevent disease but when you're taking a medication to quote unquote prevent disease,
there's no research that's going to prevent a disease. I think you could do more damage
than than good. So I would be careful of that. And if I was stable and my cancer was stable,
I would go off of those things because they can do harm. So taking, you know, fish oil can't
do harm but, you know, taking fenmentazole can do harm. Well, you can test for these things. That's
why I ask people to promise that you're going to go on fenmentazole but you've got to be getting
a comprehensive metabolic profile on a monthly basis at least. And so you can look at their
AST, ALT and alkaline phosphatase and then it is, you know, if there is damage to the liver
that we need to back off, I hope that helps.